hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the course of
the speech that he gives praising love
Erik Symmachus the physician the
practitioner of the art of medicine is
going to talk about other arts as well
he's going to after saying that medicine
looks to the body and how to regulate
its flows and its pleasures and desires
and its order and structure he talks
about gymnastics and then immediately he
switches to music he's going to talk
quite a bit about this and it might seem
a little bit of a digression not least
since he brings up Heraclitus in hard to
say Heraclitus got some things right but
also to criticize Heraclitus but he
really sees a strong parallel between
what medicine is doing and what music is
doing and this is something that you'll
see as a platonic theme not just
something that people involved with the
art of medicine might have said but also
Plato himself is going to say in the
Republic in the gorges and in other
places as well he's going to talk about
these important types of Arts and how
they fit in with each other so medicine
just to recap produces health or helps
to move from a diseased state to a
healthy state why by imposing a kind of
good law of a harmony on two opposed
elements and the elements were physical
things like the hot and the cold of the
white and the dry or the bitter and the
sweet and there might be a whole bunch
of these eric Senecas is not actually
trying to give us an exhaustive medical
treatise at this point or outline you
know what the whole metaphysics of the
system is but do you think that medicine
is able to do what it does by
introducing good love good love is a
kind of harmony a kind of Concord
between the elements that he brings up
Heraclitus and he says Heraclitus has
this interesting passage
Heraclitus by the way is often called
Heraclitus the obscure because in part
we don't have that much of his work and
in part because he would say things that
were seen as enigmatic so Heraclitus
talks about the one that's in conflict
in itself being held together like the
harmony of the bow and the wire so he's
talking about something else perhaps a
cosmic principle and then he's likening
it to the harmony of the ball right bow
and arrow you stretch out the bow you
produce force in part by by pulling back
the the not the arrow the string is it
is in a certain way opposed to the bow
itself the arm is being opposed to the
bow and that's what allow something to
happen that's what allows the motion to
take place something that the the Greeks
are very familiar with also the wire so
the lyre is one of the important early
instruments and it's got multiple
strings it doesn't have France or
anything like that that's another way to
make multiple sounds out of an
instrument right instead it gives a
whole sequence of strings and you play
the string that you want to hear another
instrument that's very similar would be
the harp now is the lyre in harmony with
itself in the same way that the bow is
no not exactly the same way there's
there's a different type of metaphor
here
you could create a harmony in part by
playing what we nowadays call an
arpeggio play a chord right play the
first the third the fifth by the way the
Greeks were already becoming very
familiar with the mathematics of this
through through Pythagoras now Erickson
MCUs is going to say
Heraclitus is a little bit obscure on
this point in part because he seems to
think that the one can actually be in
conflict with itself if it's really in
conflict it's with itself it's not a one
it's not a unity there has to be some
sort of Concord there in order for these
opposed elements to actually be in one
sort of unity but then he has this list
this statement that he says it's quite
interesting
it's a essentially an identity statement
saying this is this and this is this so
we can think about it in terms of the
transitive property if a equals B B
equals C equals C he's saying that on
harmony a Harmonia in Greek is a Concord
is a agreement right a symphonia a you
know many voices together or multiple
voices together it'd be a literal way of
translating symphonia that itself is
also an agreement or a sympathia
sometimes how it's translated a whole
logia again a sameness of logia of
speaking articulation and this is a homo
lugia an agreement of things that are
different from each other things that DF
favoring literally that's that's
separated heart so there is this this
property of bringing together involved
in harmony or our Concord things that
would normally on their own repulse each
other we've already seen this with the
art of Medicine how does this play out
in terms of the art of music now of
course you know he's not trying to do a
treason you know musical theory there's
other types of opposition that we could
bring up Plato himself will talk about
the different modes in other things in
other
texts and show us that he understands a
bit more about music that he's putting
in the mouths of Erickson because who by
the way it says you know we need to go
to an expert to get any deeper into the
details about this but he says there's
there's two important ways that music is
bringing together opposites it's
bringing together the high and the low
in harmony so what does he mean by this
we have to imagine perhaps that we could
think of the octave you know when you
play a single note and then you play the
note that's eight above it well that's
eighth and the sequence seven above it's
seven full full steps twelve you know
half steps above it that sounds nice
right it sounds different than just
playing the note by itself this is why
actually in you know heavy metal if you
want to make a song sound particularly
heavy you have the bass playing the same
thing as the guitars riff but the bass
is playing at the same note the same
root note and a you know one octave down
perhaps even two octaves down depending
on what you're doing
you can also do this with with other
things you know the first and the fifth
that gives you if you just put those two
together that gives you a particularly
strong sort of sound that's the root of
a power chord by the way we might also
think of melody as doing something like
this ranging you know bringing together
high and low notes Erickson MCUs of
course isn't getting too much of the
details and that's but you can you can
go a little bit further with that then
he also talks about a different
dimension and this is important when
we're thinking about music because music
happens in time you don't just play one
chord and then just let the hurry
through the entire concert right or hold
one note for the entire you know opera
or symphony or whatever you have to have
alternation of fast and slow we do the
same thing by the way the language the
ancient Greeks in poetry they didn't
have what we call end run where you know
roses are red violets are blue bla bla
bla bla that are ended with an O right
that's end rhyme the Greeks instead had
metre rhythm was was part of the way
that things were arranged so for example
here's here's you know one poem from
Aristophanes the frogs you know the frog
say Branca kick xqo Ox Cox breca kick ex
coax coax the Cox Cox those are longer
those are longer segments right there
but I could get kicks fast fast fast
slow slow slow slow
right I forget exactly whose poem this
is but there's a holla post may feel a
slight Halep or how the posted though
feel a sigh how about that are on the
punt on a phantom and on Podesta right
you hear the rhythm involved in that and
the Greeks were particularly attuned to
that whether it was poetry or whether it
was music so we can talk about music is
incorporating the faster the slow and in
both of these cases we have a
harmonization taking place a bringing
together things that are different
things that are opposed to each other
that's what what Eric's amicus says is
going out of music here's where it gets
really interesting now the art of music
can be applied to human activities
thinking about all the things that we
provide musical scores to from standing
in the elevator where you hear you know
the proverbial music elevator music we
call it that defines a certain kind of
activity it's opposed to being a light
listening and all that think about what
people workout - it's not usually you
know super soft stuff unless they're
doing yoga but if they're lifting
weights it's probably going to be
something a bit more you know robust
there's music that's appropriate to
certain things and then music that's
less appropriate and picking the wrong
kind of music can put people in the raw
frame of mind so just like how medicine
produces certain effects within the body
by producing good or bad love by
producing harmony or symphony or discord
and and dissolution music can do the
same thing in human activities it has a
psychological effect Erickson mcus talks
about it as connected with our desires
and with our pleasures and he cautions
against provoking the wrong kind of
desires with music or encouraging people
in the wrong sorts of pleasures with
music again something that we're going
to see Plato himself talking about in
the mouths of Socrates in the Republic
in a different dialogue right now he
brings the two together finally by
saying you know the art of Medicine one
of the things that were able to do with
it is allow people to enjoy the
pleasures of the table there they're
allowed to enjoy a certain amount of
unhealthy eating because you balance it
out with healthy things and you use the
art of medicine to make sure they're not
going to really do damage to themselves
he says the art of music can do
something quite similar the person who's
actually skilled in music can let us
enjoy a bit of the stuff that's a little
bit risky a little bit going too far
if we just listen to that all the time
it would screw us up they understand the
right amount of proportion for that
there's a certain order that should be
imposed that's what he's saying the art
of music does so the art of music works
with love just as much as medicine does
as a matter of fact they work almost in
parallel or in tandem with each other